what is the processes that those they go
through in their particular cultural
space to cope when there's adversity or
protective factors are the mechanisms
the processes that systems at different
levels whether it's an education system
or an individual child or indeed up even
a political system I'm interested in how
people perceive their own resilience and
how they understand their capacity in
their agency to deal with different
types of shocks and disturbances and to
actually affect change you know in
positive ways you can you can either ask
individuals to change but actually the
truth is that you can also help people
through a lot of period of change by
changing the environments around them by
creating more facilitative communities
better social policies better
transportation systems it's less of a
burden on the individual to wake up
every morning say okay I've got to cope
with this new world because that new
world is going to facilitate that gentle
nudge in the right direction
I think that sefa gives us this great
opportunity to tackle some of these big
global challenges and it also is really
encouraging us to be quite bold and to
really move outside our comfort zones
and I think that some of the intractable
problems that we've been talking about
over the last few days where we think
coming together and bringing these
different disciplinary perspectives and
developing this multi systemic approach
can really help to answer some of these
tricky questions and suddenly you're
talking about these very complex models
of watching systems adapt and transform
when they're under stress so that they
are more sustainable and a deep more
promoting of health and well-being
[Music]
you